[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we'll be tackling a couple of questions
the first being how did Dumbledore
defeat Gallic Grindelwald and the second
question being why didn't grindelwald go
to Azkaban we know Gellert Grindelwald
as one of the darkest and most powerful
wizards of all time considered by most
to be second to only Lord Voldemort in
terms of sheer power as far as dark
wizards go in a list of most dangerous
dark wizards of all time he would miss
out on the top spot only because you
know who arrived a generation later to
steal his crown Rita Skeeter wrote
Grindelwald was born in the year 1883
and in his younger years he was a
student at durmstrang Institute while
attending the school Grindelwald
sadistic nature showing through and he
was expelled for experimenting with
twisted and dark magic when he left
school Grindelwald met a young Albus
Dumbledore and the two spent every
minute together I think that the magical
power of each young man can be partly
attributed to the time that they spent
with each other though Dumbledore and
Grindelwald were close
there was definitely a crossroads where
the two began to go down very different
paths
it was Grindelwald intention to find the
Deathly Hallows then lead a Wizarding
revolution that would effectively put an
end to the International statute of
secrecy breaking down the secretive
divide between the two worlds this
revolution would create a global power
hierarchy that would place powerful
witches and wizards at the top of the
food chain effectively giving them full
control of muggles and mukil affairs
Dumbledore and Grindelwald eventually
parted ways after a three-way duel that
included Dumbledore's brother Aberforth
the jewel resulted in the death of Albus
sister Ariana and it effectively put an
end to their relationship after parting
ways with Dumbledore Grindelwald stole
the elder one from me cue Gregorovitch
who held the one at that time
Gregorovitch the proprietor of a one
shop started spreading rumors about his
possession of the one
hoping that it would improve business
this was a foolish and fatal error as
Grindelwald stole the wand from his
workshop in the middle of the night
after stealing the wand Grindelwald
began to amass his following a legion of
fanatics that would help him to
facilitate all sorts of attacks across
europe Grindelwald is responsible for
committing some of the most heinous
crimes that you could think of including
mass slaughtering of wizards and even
attacks on muggles at the height of his
power he was seemingly unstoppable with
an army of fanatics in the possession of
the Elder Wand there was only one person
who could stop him
Dumbledore Dumbledore was the yin to
Grindelwald the yang and the two had a
rich history each of them able to
attribute much of their magical
capabilities to the time that they spent
together in their formative years when
Dumbledore graduated from Hogwarts he
returned to Godric's Hollow to be with
his family after death of his mother
Kendra Dumbledore Albus being the eldest
sibling knew that he would have to take
care of his younger siblings
particularly Ariana who had problems
controlling her magical abilities it was
during this time that Albus became
friends with Gellert Grindelwald a young
man who had moved to his small village
to live with his aunt Matilda Bagshot
who was a family friend of the
Dumbledore's and greenwalls great-aunt
the two immediately recognized that they
were different and had magical
capabilities far surpassing the average
witch or wizard because of this the two
boys hit it off immediately though it is
not directly stated I am sure that the
friendship between Dumbledore and
Grindelwald undoubtedly resulted in
increasingly powerful magical abilities
for both boys as they were able to
challenge each other's abilities on a
consistent basis before befriending
Grindelwald
Albus always out shown every other witch
and wizard that he interacted with
regardless of how powerful they were
Grindelwald great-aunt Matilda Bagshot
was a gifted magical historian and the
author of history of magic which was
used to teach students at Hogwarts from
this we can assume that powerful magic
was clearly in grinned Awards bloodline
and as a result he became a very
powerful wizard at a young age just like
Dumbledore the coexistence of the two
young powerful Wizards meant that they
were challenged by another for the first
time resulting in even greater power for
the both of them so they're both
immensely powerful wizards but was
Dumbledore truly more powerful than
Grindelwald even with the Elder Wand how
did he defeat him how was grinning
world's reign of terror finally stopped
as Grindelwald grew in power over the
years the public opinion quickly became
the Dumbledore would be the only man
capable of stopping him because of
Dumbledore and Grindelwald history
Dumbledore initially shrugged it off
allowing Grindelwald to become more and
more powerful as the years progressed in
truth the main reason for Dumbledore's
unwillingness to fight Grindelwald was
that in their youth Grindelwald and
Dumbledore entered into a Blood Pact
this Blood Pact sealed by magic stated
that the two would never be able to
fight each other the Blood Pact was
stored in a vial that was kept on green
Awards person and it was not until 1927
when Newt Scamander stole the vial that
the possibility of the two battling
became a reality
sometime between 1927 and 1945 the vial
containing the Blood Pact was destroyed
allowing the two great wizards to clash
once more Grindelwald actions had become
too terrible and his level of power was
reaching insane new heights because of
this Dumbledore knew that he finally had
to take action in the year 1945 a duel
finally occurred between the elder one
wielding Grindelwald and the powerful
Albus Dumbledore British pureblood
Wizard of Fire stowed described their
duel as the greatest of all time and
that no duel ever matched it I can't
wait to see this on screen as my
favorite battle so far was the duel
between Voldemort and Dumbledore in the
Ministry atrium I wonder if they can top
it
Dumbledore was successful in edging out
Grindelwald during their duel and after
defeating him one allegiance of the
Elder Wand becoming its new
though it isn't explicitly stated
anywhere which spells are used during
their epic battle
I suspect the two were frequenting some
of their most powerful favorites
both men were masters of the elements
and displayed unmatched levels of skill
when dealing with a manipulation of the
elements with Grindelwald we've seen
these elemental spells exhibited in a
number of instances the first time being
when he unleashed a white blast of magic
instantly destroying five powerful
European auras the second time when
Grindelwald Jules Newt Scamander sending
out a spell that generated shock waves
of blue lightning and thirdly the famed
protego diabolica a powerful protective
ring of fire that incinerates anyone who
comes close to you with this spell he
was able to effortlessly fend off over
30 auras and these are just three
examples of the spells that he has he
probably has so many options to choose
from but I bet he used at least one of
these three in his jewel against
Dumbledore
but temple door has a few tricks up his
sleeve as well and over the course of
the books and films has really shown us
what he's capable of in his jewel
against Voldemort and the ministry
atrium we see his elemental expertise
shine through when he creates some sort
of complicated hydrokinetic spell in the
same duel against Voldemort we see them
with Oz Transfiguration ability shine
through as well
when he turns all of the glass shards
sent towards him into sand however I
think a Dumbledore was most impressive
display of magic was when he produced a
firestorm to ward off the in ferry
firestorm produces a large ring of fire
from the caster's wand and from this
ring the caster is able to shoot jets or
balls of fire at opponents impressive
stuff so even though we don't know
exactly which spells were cast I think
that it's safe to say that Dumbledore
definitely has the capability to destroy
Grindelwald and I'm quite eager to
finally witness which spells are used
when this jewel eventually occurs in the
film adaptation fantastic beasts
though Dumbledore was successful in
defeating Grindelwald he did spare his
life and after his defeat Grindelwald
was sent to prison as it was the year
1945 and given the facts that
Grindelwald was defeated by a British
wizard one might expect that Grindelwald
would be sent to prison with the highest
security possible a prison like Azkaban
however ironically Grindelwald was
imprisoned in nerman guard castle the
same fortress that he himself built to
hold his enemies Nermin guard was the
base camp for all of his operations
during his reign of power so it's
interesting that he would be imprisoned
in such familiar territory because of
Grindelwald ties to austria he was
imprisoned in ermengarde rather than
Azkaban this turned out to be the
appropriate choice as he never escaped
but I personally would have questioned
it at the time Azkaban is unparalleled
at securing dark witches and wizards and
has Dementors which lemon guard doesn't
have the main safeguard of nerman guard
is that the prisoners are denied their
ones similar to Azkaban I can only
assume that there must be preventative
charms placed around the castle as well
Grendel Wald was imprisoned in the
topmost prison cell in the highest town
of nerman guard and it was there that he
spent 53 years of his life before
eventually being murdered by Voldemort
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think what spell did Dumbledore use
to finally apprehend Grindelwald let me
know down in the comment section below
as always please hit the subscribe
button if you enjoy the content until
next time you're always sorry
[Music]